[Musik]
rotwald ein Überfall Chinas auf Taiwan
neben dem russischen Krieg in der
Ukraine macht auch die taiwanfrage
Sicherheitsexperten große Sorgen zumal
sich ähnlich wie Putin auch der
chinesische präsidentischen pink mit
martialischer Rhetorik nicht zurückhält
es steht eine Wende bevor wie sie seit
100 Jahren nicht mehr stattgefunden hat
und wir treiben diese Wände gemeinsam
voran zu Vladimir Putin am 22 März 2023
während seine Staatsbesuchs in Moskau
sagt er bereitet China auf einen Krieg
vor die Welt sollte ihn ernst nehmen im
März sprach Ski in vier verschiedenen
reden über das Thema Kriegsbereitschaft
und forderte seine Generäle in einer
davon auf den Kampf zu wagen in Peking
hat sich ein wandelvollzogen den
politischen Entscheidungsträger und
Wirtschaftsführer weltweit nicht
ignorieren können wenn sie sagt dass er
sich auf einen Krieg vorbereite wäre es
töricht ihn nicht beim Wort zu nehmen
eines ist sicher US-Präsident Joe Biden
gehört ganz bestimmt nicht zu jener
törichten Gruppe von Menschen die
schießen Worte nicht ernst nehmen
deswegen hat er schon zuvor eine ganz
klare Ansage gemacht beiden
US-Streitkräfte würden Taiwan im Falle
einer chinesischen Invasion verteidigen
wird 2024 also das Schicksals ja in dem
der nächste Weltkrieg ausbricht der
Oberbefehlshaber der US-Marine waren das
China vor 2024 in Taiwan einmarschieren
könnte alle Augen der Welt sind und
bleiben daher noch lange auf die Insel
in der Straße von Formosa gerichtet doch
die taiwanfrage ist in Wirklichkeit nur
Teil eines viel größeren geopolitischen
Puzzles in der Asien Pazifik Region
[Musik]
denn das regime-schi in Pinks will nicht
nur Taiwan übernehmen nein es will auch
die dominierende Macht in diesem Winkel
der weltwärmen und dafür muss es ein
großes Hindernis überwinden denn es gibt
dort schon einen Platzhirschen die
us-ofa bevor ich fortfahren möchte ich
euch jedoch eine Frage stellen welcher
ist der größte Verbündete der USA in der
Region klar hier kämen Japan Südkorea
oder Taiwan selbst in Frage aber das
Land das Washington politisch
wirtschaftlich und kulturell am nächsten
steht ist niemand anderes als Australien
und ein gewisser Weise erklärt das auch
Nachrichten wie diese
Australien kritisiert Chinas Politik der
wirtschaftlichen Bestrafung bei der
Welthandelsorganisation und beschuldigt
das Land gegen die Regeln zu verstoßen
Australiens Premierminister strebt ein
Ende der chinesischen Handelssanktionen
an in den vergangenen Jahren haben sich
die Beziehungen zwischen China und
Australien immer weiter verschlechtert
aus einer ganz guten
handelspartnerschaft in der man sich
gegenseitig respektierte ist so etwas
wie ein fieser Nachbarschaftsstreit
geworden zwei Seiten die sich rund um
die Uhr belauern und sich bei jeder
Gelegenheit in den Haaren liegen ja es
gab ständig ärgert doch im Mai 2022
änderte sich etwas die leberparty
übernahm die australische Regierung eine
Ehre Prioritäten ist es die Beziehungen
zu China zu verbessern das heißt aber
nicht dass der Sturm abgeflaut ist ganz
und gar nicht
[Musik]
Australien ist eines der wirtschaftlich
erfolgreichsten Länder der vergangenen
Jahrzehnte es ist richtig reich um seine
Lebensqualität gilt als eine der besten
der Welt es ist bis auf den
angstgetriebenen Lockdown Irrsinn den es
sich ausgerechnet von China abgeschaut
hat auch eine starke Demokratie mit
einer blühenden Zivilgesellschaft und es
zieht viele Einwanderer an die von einem
besseren Leben träumen deshalb sind
Themen wie Freiheit und Menschenrechte
in Australien wichtig und Sie werden
immer wichtiger und vielleicht ist
dieses liberale Land das so gut mit den
Amerikanern auskommt gerade deshalb dazu
verdammt mit Peking aneinander zu
geraten oder besser gesagt Kendra ist
mittlerweile zu einem großen
Ärgernis für pink geworden und das wird
sich wohl auch so schnell nicht ändern
und genau dieser Punkt hat in letzter
Zeit viel Analysten dazu veranlasst eine
ebenso klare wie verstörende Frage zu
stellen was wäre wenn der Konflikt
zwischen China und den besten in
Australien und nicht in Taiwan beginnen
würde natürlich reden wir nicht von
Soldaten der sogenannten chinesischen
Volksbefreiungsarmee die versuchen ihre
Flaggen australischen Outback
aufzustellen nein darüber brauchen wir
jetzt noch nicht zu reden diese
Möglichkeit überlassen wir der Fantasie
von Filmautoren das reale Risiko das auf
dem Tisch liegt ist ganz anders
gestrickt china könnte versuchen
Australien zu blockieren ja quasi zu
belagern und vom wichtigen Welthandel
abzutrennen mit gravierenden globalen
Folgen schließlich würde dies einen
Domino-Effekt Auslösen der in der ganzen
Welt spürbar wäre und genau aus diesem
Grund nehmen wir im heutigen Video genau
unter die Lupe was Australien eigentlich
so wertvoll macht aber auch warum ist so
verwundbar ist bevor wir ihn doch so
richtig loslegen wollen wir euch mal
wieder einen kleinen Einblick in unseren
Redaktionsalltag gewähren also
aufgepasst wir vielleicht wisst gibt es
visualpolitik in verschiedenen Sprachen
auch z.B auf Spanisch da die Themen für
jedes Video immer von mehreren Autoren
arbeitet werden muss ich mich schon des
öfter mit meinem spanischen Kollegen von
ca abstimmen und das sieht dann so aus
von Ende der Themas es Tastatur
[Musik]
okay so geht es nicht weiter ich muss
endlich ordentlich Spanisch lernen nicht
nur wegen der Arbeit sondern auch für
den Urlaub in diesem wunderschönen Land
was aber ist der beste Weg gerade für
jemanden wie mich der eigentlich keine
Zeit dazu hat und auch lernen muss ganz
normal umgangssprachlich mit
ungeduldigen schnellsprechern von
umzugehen und die Antwort ist klar
Babbel denn mit der Bubble App kann ich
mir meine eigenen Lernziele festlegen um
den Unterricht nach Belieben zu
gestalten du glaubst mir nicht dann
probiere es aus bereits mit drei bis
fünf Minuten täglich erreichst du
deutliche Fortschritte in der Fokus von
Babbel liegt auf dem Erlernen von
gesprächsfähigkeiten die du direkt im
realen Leben anwenden kannst die Lektion
wurden entsprechend von
hochprofessionellen Sprachlehrern
entwickelt vor allem bietet Babbel auch
14 Sprachen und ein ganzes Ökosystem mit
vielen verschieden Bubble ist nicht nur
eine einfache App Bubble das sind
Podcast Zeitschriften Artikel Spiele und
aber tausende von regelmäßig
aktualisierten Inhalten die von echten
Sprachexperten und echten Muttersprachen
verpasst worden und wenn du Babbel über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung
abonniert erhältst du ganze 50% Rabatt
auf den lebenslangen Zugang zu allen
Sprachen außerdem als wir so alt Politik
Community Bonus zwei kostenlose live
online Kurse oben drauf natürlich kannst
du das alles dank Geld zurück Garantie
ausgiebig testen bevor du dich
entscheidest also worauf wartest du noch
schau dir einmal über den Link zu diesem
Video an und vielleicht wirst du auch
schon bald Senior von Sega in unseren
spanischen Videos verstehen können und
bevor ich es vergesse ebenfalls in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video findest
du eine Spenden Link über den du unsere
Arbeit auf freiwilliger Basis direkt
unterstützen kannst wir alle inklusive
Senior von seca danken dir
so und nun lasst uns aufbrechen auf eine
Reise nach Down Under und das hochgradig
kritische thematis Videos ausgiebig zu
analysieren die mögliche Belagerung
Australien durch China als Joker und
Faust fand im Machtkampf oder gar Krieg
gegen den Westen aufgepasst
[Musik]
wie Australien 3
australien ist ein Ungeheuer reiches
Land ein Australier ist im Schnitt viel
reicher als ein deutscher das ozeanische
Land hat zum Beispiel dass er 9 höchste
pro Kopf BIP der Welt und das 7 höchste
mittlere Haushaltseinkommen in der ui-cd
aber nicht nur das seine Wirtschaft ist
ein echter Feld in der Brandung des
Südpazifiks in Australien gibt es kaum
Arbeitslosigkeit die Arbeitslosenquote
liegt derzeit bei rund 3,7 %
volkswirtschaftlich gesehen handelt es
sich um Vollbeschäftigung und seit 1992
hat die australische Wirtschaft nur ein
einziges Krisenjahr erlebt ich rede von
2020 als Corona die Welt heimsuchte und
die Australier in Panik versetzte aber
nicht einmal die Pandemie und extreme
lockdowns konnten dieses Land aufhalten
im ersten Quartal 2021 wuchs die
Wirtschaft wieder robust und das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt war höher als vor
den lockdowns
die australische Wirtschaft befindet
sich auf einem positiven Weg die
Produktion liegt jetzt über dem Niveau
vor der Pandemie und mehr Australier
haben einen Job als davor wer vielleicht
wichtigste Punkt ist folgender die
Australier sitzen auf einer gigantischen
Menge Geld das zu Finanzierung aller
möglichen Projekte bereitsteht ihr wollt
zahlen das durchschnittliche
Nettovermögen eines australischen
Haushalts beträgt etwa 550.000 US Dollar
ja ihr habt richtig gehört mehr als eine
halbe Million Dollar und im Median
Vermögen pro Kopf liegt das Land bei
rund 274 000 US-Dollar das ist mehr als
in den USA weltweit übertreffen da nur
Luxemburg und Island die aussieht
[Musik]
und natürlich ist es bei solchen Daten
nicht verwunderlich dass es so viele
Auswanderer aus aller Welt dorthin zieht
ich rede hier aber von gut ausgebildeten
Migranten von Menschen die was können
von Menschen die Unternehmen in
Australien Gründen überhaupt ist dort
die gründungsrate von Unternehmen eine
der höchsten der Welt so ist es auch
nicht verwunderlich dass downloa auch
Platz zwei steht in der Liste der Länder
mit den besten Lebensbedingungen es
handelt sich hierbei um eine jährliches
Ranking der OCD und diese Liste kann man
auch entnehmen das Australien das tritt
beste Gesundheitssystem der Welt hat man
kann also mit Flug und Recht behaupten
es gibt nicht nur einen American Dream
sondern auch einen Australian Dream und
dieser ist vielleicht noch besser
die wirtschaftlichen Probleme die das
Land derzeit hat sind eher Luxusprobleme
die manch einer gerne haben würde
Australien braucht die Rückkehr
ausländische Rucksack Touristen das Land
steht vor einem der schlimmsten
Arbeitskräfte Mängel der Reichen Welt
Arbeitskräftemangel bedroht Australiens
Aufschwung nach der Pandemie die
Arbeitslosigkeit hat ein 50-jahres-tief
erreicht aber die Unternehmen haben
Schwierigkeiten Arbeitskräfte zu finden
ganz ehrlich das ist Kleinkram und geht
vorüber die Touris werden wiederkommen
die Arbeitskräfte auch aber das Beste
für die australische Nation könnte noch
kommen und ihr warum nun das liegt vor
allem am Hunger der Welt nach
vermeintliche sauberer und elektrische
Energie die fossile Energieträger
ablösen soll
[Musik]
Elektroautos Windturbinen Solarzellen
Batterien für die Herstellung all dieser
Produkte braucht es Rohstoffe wie Kobalt
Nickel Lithium und Kupfer der Wandel ist
so tiefgreifend dass nach Schätzungen
der Weltbank die Produktion einige
dieser Mineralien versetztfacht werden
muss um die enorme Nachfrage zu
befriedigen die sich hier weltweit
abzeichnen aber was hat das alles
eigentlich mit Australien zu tun und was
mit Chinas Streben nach Dominanz nun
wegen seiner Rohstoffe ist Australien
mittlerweile eines der geostrategischen
wichtigsten Länder der Welt geworden es
ist nicht nur eine der weltgrößten
Produzenten von Gold Eisenerz Kohle Zink
und Bauxit es ist mittlerweile auch eine
Supermarkt bei all den neuen Rohstoffen
nach denen die Welt jetzt so leicht die
Reserven Australiens an Nickel kobal
Lithium und Kupfer gehören zu den
größten der Welt tatsächlich ist es
bereits heute der größte Lithium
Produzent und der zweitgrößte
kobaltproduzent auf diesen Planeten
außerdem verfügt das Land über enorme
Vorkommen an seltenen Erben was ist so
eine Alternative zu China macht
wohlgemerkt zu einer demokratischen und
verlässlichen Alternative die Welt hat
ja seit vorigen Jahr gelernt dass man
sich lieber nicht von großen Diktaturen
abhängig macht wenn es um wichtige
Rohstoffe geht und als ob das alles noch
nicht genug wäre Australien gehört zu
der Top 3 der weltgrößten Exporteure von
flüssig Erdgas ja ihr habt richtig
gehört es teilt sich diesen Sieger
Podest mit den USA und Katar
es ist sicherlich nicht von Nachteil
eine Weltmacht bei LNG zu sein den
Brennstoff um dem sich die halbe Welt
derzeit streitet wir verlinken euch
unsere Videos dazu aber wartet ein
Moment Australien hat zugleich auch die
weltgrößten Reserven an Uran das ist
gerade jetzt enorm lukrativ jetzt wo die
Kernenergie weltweit wieder in Mode
kommt und als ob das noch nicht genug
wäre hat das Land auch einen gut
entwickelten Finanzsektor also zusammen
mit dem Rohstoffreichtum seine
Lebensqualität und seiner extremen
Anziehungskraft für qualifizierte
Einwanderer wird es wie ein Land mit
einer goldenen Zukunft
man kann das ganze sogar auf eine ganz
simple Formel bringen immer wenn es in
derzeitigen Debatten um den Klimawandel
geht dann bedeutet dies das in
Australien die Kassen klingeln werden
das Land hat quasi den Jackpot geknackt
wenn man nur auf seine Ressourcen und
seine Potenziale schaut aber es gibt da
noch den übel lautigen Nachbarn im
Norden das Land das kleine Insel
einschüttert und im Ballon Business so
aktiv ist ja wir reden von China und von
diesen Nachbarn muss sich die Regierung
in Canberra in Acht nehmen denn China
könnte eine Achillesferse der Australier
ausnutzen wollt ihr wissen worüber genau
reden nun hört jetzt gut
[Musik]
der Drache versus den Koala
china ist der größte Handelspartner
Australiens praktisch 30 bis 40 Prozent
aller Exporte des Landes gehen an den
asiatischen riesen tatsächlich waren die
Beziehung zwischen den beiden Ländern
einmal so gut da siehschenping 2014 eine
Rede immer australischen Parlament hielt
damals erntete er dafür großen Beifall
fast wie ein gewisser Wladimir Putin im
Deutschen Bundestag tja wie sich die
Geschichte doch manchmal reimt damals
unterzeichneten die beiden Länder sogar
ehrgeiziges Freihandelsabkommen doch
drei Jahre später begann ist zu kriseln
im Jahr 2017 Beklagten australische
Behörden die zunehmende Einmischung
Chinas in die Politik des Landes und man
versuchte diesen Einfluss einzudämmen
2018 wurde Huawei aus Sicherheitsgründen
von der Entwicklung des vfg Netzes
ausgeschlossen später forderte
Australien die Einhaltung der
Menschenrechte in Ching Chang und
Hongkong und schließlich forderte die
australische Regierung sogar eine
Untersuchung der Verantwortung Chinas
für den Ausbruch und die Ausbreitung des
Coronavirus all das sorgte natürlich für
enorme Verärgerung entwickeln und im
beleidigt sein geübt antworteten die
Chinesen schnell mit einem ganzen
Katalog von Strafen da wurden
diplomatische Kontakte abgebrochen und
hochgängige politische treffen
ausgesetzt stattdessen verhängte man
Strafzölle unbeug konnte gegen viele
australische Produkte von Holz über Wein
und Kohle bis hin zu human und
landwirtschaftlichen Produkten China
Verbot sogar seinen Touristen nach down
anders zu reisen wir haben darüber
damals ein eigenes Video gedreht dass
ich euch hinter dem oben rechts
verlinken werde damit ihr es euch später
ansehen könnt
im Jahr 2020 gab es sogar einen groß
angelegten Cyberangriff auf Australien
China wurde nicht direkt beschuldigt
aber man ist sich heute sicher dass es
die Chinesen waren im April 2022 hatte
ich chinesische Regierung dann ein
Sicherheitsabkommen mit den Salomonen
unterzeichnet auch darüber haben wir
schon in einem früheren Video berichtet
danke dieses Abkommens könnte China die
Fähigkeit erhalten australische Gewässer
zu erreichen zu überwachen und sogar
militärisch zu kontrollieren und dies
ist genau der Punkt von dem in diesem
Video die Rede ist
mit seiner schnell wachsenden Marine und
Luftwaffe könnte ich China im
Konfliktfall in der Lage sein die
Schifffahrtswege des australischen
Handels zu stören oder sogar zu
blockieren dies ist das größte Risiko
für die nationale Sicherheit der
Australien und zugleich das größte
erpressungsinstrument das Peking in der
Hand haben könnte warum nur gleich
werdet ihr den Grund verstehen wir reden
hier nicht nur über die Unterbrechung
von Exporten und Import sondern über
etwas potenziell viel erster ist
[Musik]
Australien hat einen seltenen Status auf
den weltweiten Energiemärkten es ist
sowohl ein großer Importeur als auch ein
großer Exporteur lass mich das erklären
das Land verbraucht mehr Öl als je zuvor
es produziert weniger als noch vor einem
jahrzehn seine Notreserven sind auf dem
Tiefpunkt und es hat kaum noch
Kapazitäten um selbst Kraftstoffe zu
produzieren während das Land im Jahr
2008 verfügte die den gesamten
Inlandsmarkt versorgten sind es heute
nur noch zwei das Ergebnis ist eine
wachsende Abhängigkeit vom Ausland
obwohl Australien weiterhin etwas Öl
exportiert importiert ist 90% der
petrochemischen Kraftstoffe die es
verbraucht und die kommen hauptsächlich
Ausländern wie Südkorea Singapur Japan
Malaysia und Taiwan
es gibt hierzu eine sehr interessante
vom australischen
Verteidigungsministerium in Auftrag
gegebener Analyse demnach könnte China
im Konflikt weil das Südchinesische Meer
und das Ostchinesische Meer ab Regeln
und damit einem Großteil der
australischen Treibstoffversorgung
blockieren Öl und treibstofftanker
würden dann Australien gar nicht mehr
oder nur über viel längere und teurere
Routen erreichen all das könnte die
australische Wirtschaft in nur wenigen
Wochen lahmlegen zugegeben ja wir haben
eben davon gesprochen dass ich die Welt
gerade unabhängig von fossilen
Brennstoffen macht und auf alternative
Energien dabei eine Hauptrolle spielt
aber trotz dieser rosigen
Zukunftsaussichten ist die australische
Wirtschaft noch lange nicht unabhängig
von Erdöl und daraus produzierten Kraft
und Schmierstoffen und es gibt noch eine
weitere Abhängigkeit Australien ist
vielleicht das westlichste Land das am
meisten von China abhängig ist wenn es
um die Lieferung wichtiger Produkte und
Komponenten für seine Industrie geht
von düngemittelnsäure über Aluminium bis
hin zu allen Arten von chemischen
Verbindungen und Maschinen mit anderen
Worten angesichts der neuen Krise könnte
China versuchen die australische
Wirtschaft lernzulegen es handelt sich
über ein enormes robotential über das
china verfügt und es erklärt Nachrichten
wie diese über 60% der Australier sagen
dass China eher eine Bedrohung für
Australien als ein Wirtschaftspartner
sei das ist ein spektakulärer Wandel
2018 waren es nur 12 %. bedeutet das nur
das Australien den blauen Pekings
ausgeliefert ist nun zum Glück nicht
Australien hat drei große Vorteile es
ist ein sehr reiches Land es ist der
beste Verbündete der Vereinigten Staaten
in der Region und es nimmt die Bedrohung
durch China mittlerweile sehr sehr ernst
in den letzten Jahren hat can brush eine
bilateralen sicherheitsbeziehung mit
anderen Ländern in der Region
insbesondere mit Japan gestärkt wir
konnten live beobachten die Bündnisse
wie die Quad die five ICE und der neue
induktive wirtschaftsrahmen gestärkt
worden dazu haben wir hier auf
visualpolitik schon mehrere Videos
gedreht die ich euch in der Beschreibung
verlinken werde vor allem haben wir
gesehen wie das Bündnis mit den USA
gestärkt wurde da gibt es mittlerweile
das Programm das Aquarium steht für die
Länder australia uk und USA also
Australien Großbritannien und USA es ist
vielleicht kein echtes
Verteidigungsmittel die Natur aber es
ist eine Sicherheitspartnerschaft in der
die genannten Länder militärisch
zusammenarbeiten es geht dabei auch
umrüstungsgüter die Australien erhalten
wird zum Beispiel U-Boote und
Marschflugkörper es gibt gemeinsame
Militärübungen und man tauscht sich auch
geheimdienstlich aus auch zu Orgas
verlinke ich euch ein Video schaut euch
im an fangen mal an die Stärkung der
Beziehungen zu Uncle Sam war nämlich
auch eine sehr klare Botschaft an China
falls das Reich der Mitte versucht
Australien zu blockieren wird es einen
hohen Preis dafür zahlen müssen die USA
würden möglicherweise die Blockade
verhindern oder die orkesländer könnten
eine Art gegenblokade installieren und
zwar ganz einfach indem sie die
Öllieferungen aus dem Nahen Osten an
China blockieren man muss dazu diese
drei wasserstraßenkappen die auf dem
Bildschirm sehen denn das ist wiederum
eine der großen Schwächen Chinas diese
drei mehr Engel sind die Lebensadern des
Drachen er selbst hat also auch eine
Achillesferse wie z.B Nachrichten wie
die folgende beweisen
US Beschlagnahmung eines Öltankers löste
Kaperung eines Tankers durch den Iran
aus wie USA hat ein interveniert um
einen mit iranischen Schiff das
ursprünglich für China bestimmt war aus
dem Verkehr zu ziehen fakt ist China ist
nicht in der Lage mit seiner Marine
seine eigenen vitalen versorgungsadern
zu sichern das können nur die USA mit
der stärksten nie wieder der Welt können
sie als einzige aber auch ganz einfach
von seinem ganzen Lebens Elixier
abschneiden das ist auch der Grund warum
Australien immer noch sehr daran
interessiert ist an der Seite der
Vereinigten Staaten zu stehen und eines
ist auch klar Chinas
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Australien
sind gescheitert vor allem dank der
Unterstützung durch andere asiatische
Handelspartner die sich an Australien
wandten um ihre Energieversorgung
sicherzustellen Japan Korea Taiwan und
Indien Australiens zwei dritt wird und
fünftgrößte Exportmärkte haben ihre
australischen Importe seit 2019 jeweils
verdoppelt und damit Chinas Angriff auf
wichtige Export Industrien Australiens
ausgeglichen auch die exporter und
Indonesien haben sich mehr als
verdoppelt und in die Philippinen sind
sie sogar um sagenhafte zweiundachtzig
Prozent gestiegen die Neuordnung der
australischen Exportmärkte wurde dabei
vor allem durch die aufgrund des
russischen Überfalls auf die Ukraine
gestiegene Nachfrage nach australischer
Kohle und LG angetrieben Japans Kohle
Importe Australien stiegen von 17
Milliarden Dollar im Jahr 2019 auf 57
Milliarden Dollar im Jahr 2022 während
die Einfuhren von LG um 70% auf 35
Milliarden Dollar in die Höhe schnellten
australische code-experte nach Korea
stiegen im gleichen Zeitraum ähnlich
wenn man alt und sage und schreibe 140%
auf 17,2 Milliarden Dollar während sich
die Einführung von australischen Gas auf
13 Milliarden Dollar sogar dreifachen
Chinas Einkäufer australischer Kohle
gingen aufgrund der Sanktion jeder von
13,7 Milliarden im Jahr 2019 auf Null
zurück und die Folgen waren dramatisch
aber an dieser Stelle kommt der große
plot-test denn sie waren nicht
dramatisch für die Australier ohne
australische Kohle kam es in China 2020
in vielen Städten zu Stromausfällen und
die Stahlproduktion litt unter der
übermäßigen Verfolgung minderwertiger
heimischer Kohle dies führte dazu eine
enorme Verkürzung der Lebensdauer der
chinesischen Koksöfen so dass die
Stahlproduktion sogar nachhaltigen
Schaden haben und so war die Kohle dann
auch der erste zuvor sanktionierte
Rohstoff den China nach dem tauberwetter
in den Handelsbeziehungen in diesem Jahr
wieder aus Australien zu kaufen gegangen
das Kind ist jedoch bereits in den
Brunnen gefallen und die Australien
denken nicht daran es wieder
herauszuholen die Veränderung des
australischen handelsprofils ist
wahrlich außergewöhnlich im Jahr 2019
bevor China seine strafkampagne startete
war das Volumen der australischen
Ausführung nach China um 81% größer als
nach Japan und Korea den zweiten und
drittgrößten Märkten die Abhängigkeit
der australischen Exportindustrie von
China unüberwindbar so wie zum Beispiel
auch die Deutschlands doch siehe da im
Jahr 2022 nur drei Jahre später lag das
Exportvolumen nach Japan und Korea mit
den chinesischen gleich auf Tendenz
steigend aber wartet ein Moment das ist
noch nicht das beste
der Wandel in Australiens handelsprofil
war nur die Generalprobe eine
Generalprobe deren Aufführung alle
anderen asiatischen Länder mit großen
Interesse mitverfolgt haben und nachdem
sie die Ergebnisse sahen sind nun in
ganz Asien sehr ähnliche Veränderungen
zu beobachten die zehn größten
asiatischen Handelspartner exklusive
China und Hongkong importieren heute 80%
mehr australische waren als China noch
vor drei Jahren waren ihre importer aus
Australien noch genauso groß wie die
Chinas und damit hat ein grundsätzlicher
Paradigmenwechsel eingesetzt
China nutzt den Zugang zu seinen Märkten
schon seit langem als Mittel und
politische Ziele im Ausland zu erreichen
der erste dokumentierte Fall über Chinas
Einsatz des Handels also Waffe stammt
aus dem Jahr 1930 in jüngster Zeit waren
noch wegen Frankreich Litauen Japan und
Südkorea und chinesischen boykotten
betroffen auch hier ging es immer um die
Durchsetzung der politischen Agenda
Pekings aber noch nie gab es eine so
große und konzertierte Kampagne wie die
gegen Australien
nach dem grandiosen sanktionsfail
scheint man nun auch in Peking erkannt
zu haben dass man nun mal nicht der
Nabel der Welt ist für den man sich
wieder gern halten möchte die
pseudo-kommunistischen Machthaber
spielten mit dem Feuer und sie
verbrannten sich an Australien sie
lieferten dadurch unfreiwillig selbst
den Beweis dass es auch gut ohne China
geht zumindest ohne das eine
diktatorische China denn es gibt ja noch
ein zweites freiheitlich demokratisches
taiwan hat nämlich sowohl die USA als
auch Indien überholt und ist nun der
viertgrößte Exportmarkt Australiens mit
Importen von knapp 30 Milliarden
US-Dollar im Jahr 2022 teilbaresische
importer australischer Kohle sind seit
2019 von 5,3 Milliarden Dollar auf 13,8
Milliarden gestiegen während sich seine
Einführung von Flüssigkeit auf 9
Milliarden US-Dollar mehr als
vervielfacht haben und wie Japan und
Korea hat auch Taiwan seine Importe
sogenannter vertrauliche Handelsgüter
massiv erhöht dabei handelt es sich um
Waren bei denen die Offenlegung der
Verkäufer des Landes angeblich
Geschäftsgeheimnis gefährden würde sie
umfassen alles von Mandeln bis zu
golfwellen aber wahrscheinlich
hauptsächlich Tonerde und Konzentrate
für Kupfer Nickel und Mangal zwischen
diesen drei Ländern sind die Käufer in
den letzten drei Jahren von zweieinhalb
Milliarden auf 12 Milliarden Dollar
angestiegen der zweitgrößte Abnehmer
australischer Kohle war im vergangenen
Jahr jedoch ein anderer erstrecklich
Chinas die Einfuhren Indiens haben sich
von 10 Milliarden auf 23 Milliarden
Dollar mehr als verdoppelt Indien ist
auch zu einem wichtigen Abnehmer
australischen Goldes geworden ist ein
Exportvolumen in den letzten drei Jahren
von 266 Millionen auf anderthalb
Milliarden Dollar gestiegen ist während
Kohle und flüssig Erdgas dem größten
Anteil angestiegen Appetit Asiens auf
australische waren ausmachen haben auch
andere von China heiß begehrte Rohstoffe
anderswo gute Absatzmärkte gefunden
Vietnam zum Beispiel wurde mit Einfuhren
im Wert von 1,7 Milliarden Dollar zum
größten Abnehmer australischer Baumwolle
zum Vergleich vor drei Jahren waren es
nur 150 Millionen Dollar ja besprechen
hier von einer 15-fachung und das ist
kein Einzelfall die indonesischen Käufe
stiegen um das Fünffache auf 515
Millionen Japans Gersten Einkäufer
stiegen um 140% auf 500 Millionen Dollar
während die Importe australischen Weizen
in der gesamten Region stark Zunahmen
das Ergebnis der chinesischen
Sanktionspolitik war also vor allem eine
riesen Rheinbach für Australien einen
besseren Beweis dafür dass jeder einfach
nicht über die Macht verfügt wirksames
Sanktion gegen andere Länder zu
verhängen kann es einfach nicht geben
und siehe da sobald sich jemand von
ihnen nicht so leicht einschüchtern
lässt wird man in Peking plötzlich ganz
klein laut kürzlich hat sich nach sechs
langen Jahren wieder mit einem
australischen Premierminister getroffen
um die Beziehungen zu kitten auch
darüber haben wir schon ein Video
gedreht doch eines ist klar dicke
Freunde werden beide Länder wohl nicht
mehr china hat die großen Stärken
Australiens einfach unterschätzt fakt
ist dieser Konflikt und sein Ausgang
haben zwei Dinge deutlich gezeigt
erstens dass China eben nicht jene
wirtschaftliche Großmacht ist vor der so
viele andere Länder zittern und zweitens
das Australien jedoch umgekehrt zu einer
Großmacht geworden ist die sich nicht
Scheunen muss dem roten Riesen auf
Augenhöhe zu begegnen notfalls in die
Knie zu zwingen wohlgemerkt nicht
alleine aber im Verbund mit seinen
starken Partner und Freunden so gut wie
allen asiatischen Ländern die Pekings
Großmacht Streben und Arroganz einfach
satt haben Australien hat aber auch
demonstriert das ist auf jeden Fall das
Geld die Ressourcen den Einfluss und den
Willen hat stärker als bisher auf der
Weltbühne aufzutreten und sich nichts
gefallen zu lassen es hat mir den USA
den mächtigsten Verbündeten den man sich
wünschen kann aber vielleicht sollte
auch umgekehrter wespenfroh sein dass
Australien sein Verbündeter ist und aus
diesem Grund werden wir uns noch in
vielen weiteren Videos detaillierter mit
Down Under diesen interessanten und
mächtigen Traumland beschäftigen
vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo plus
Glöckchen um keines davon zu verpassen
und wenn ihr das erledigt habt
interessiert uns erstmal was ihr denkt
wie beurteilt ihr die Lage im Asien
Pazifikraum ist Taiwan vielleicht nur
ein Nebenkriegsschauplatz oder
eigentlich Konflikt vollzieht sich
zwischen China und Australien sieht auch
ihr in Australien eine künftige
Großmacht und würde dir gerne in
Australien leben und die wichtigste
Frage von allen was könnte euer Land vom
australischen Beispiel lernen sollte
überhaupt irgendein Nationen vor der
chinesischen Handels macht zittern wie
immer sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem
Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt es bitte ein Like und
teils mit euren Freunden um es auch mit
Ihnen zu diskutieren natürlich freuen
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit uns hätte dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Videobeschreibung mach's gut und
bis bald
[Musik]